Say,
who are they?
They're scientists cults who were based on uh,
your uh,
psychic ability,
uh,
and on your Iq and then on your commitment to the program.
And so the program starts with we go and check black people with syphilis for
greater costs or will you do research programs on babies where we tell poor
women,
uh,
that Oh your baby died right when we're born we're,
we'll keep the baby alive and sometimes killed himself on his harvest.
Them sometimes do experiments on them.
That's why they've not a lot.
A lot of nurses have noticed now that the baby's disappear at birth and I tell
him,
oh your baby die.
That's why the governor said,
who's actually organ harvesting doctor?
He goes,
we keep the babies in love and have a discussion.
They are getting caught now cause we'd be compartmentalized leading me.
I'm confused what you're sensing.
How just never rinsed.
Yeah.
What you saying about babies?
Like what did they do with babies?
You,
you saw the governor of Virginia say we keep babies alive after they're born and
kill them.
Right.
Well I didn't see that.
I am very,
very concerned with late term abortions.
Post-Birth Joe,
do you understand?
Post-Birth how much money do you think they get?
Seven and a half pound baby.
They can keep alive for two weeks and Mama doesn't know.
So if they can register the organs and get betters bleeding me,
your DNA can make 500,000 saying they kill on the spot only gets 50 grand.
But even saying that they take the baby from the mother and the mother doesn't
know that the baby's alive.
Yeah.
You know how they engineered tomatoes?
The last on the shelf?
Yes.
You can pull all this up.
California's past.
It should've be Virginia.
Virginia is about to pass in New York trying to pass it.
California trying to pass in three other states trying to pass it to keep babies
alive and allow notice.
The governor goes,
we don't want the three minute clip.
Pull it up.
We don't want the Glove Min vol.
The doctors and the mother who's drug dubs?
You didn't say that.
Oh go on.
I'm just sad about the future and maybe she keeps baby alive a week.
Maybe she sat to get rid of baby.
Wait a minute.
Is this a viable baby?
There's nothing wrong with this baby viable.
The Senate voted three days ago on Monday
to not pass the bill for post birth abortion to not kill livable post burdens
has viable.
Baby's already born can be killed if the bioethics port.
I bet you 10 million's probably that up,
Jamie.
We've got to figure it out of the listeners want,
believe me.
What'd you go?
Crazy post about this?
But it says that he did.
It's been taken out of context.
What does that media matters when he Snopes Huffington posts is that snaps?
It's,
it's mostly false.
Ah,
Huffington snope said
Jamie,
go to,
you'd go to the source of the governor,
go to youtube and type in governor of Virginia talks about post birth abortion.
Watch the unedited three minute videos and you call it abortion if it's already
been born.
Well,
that's what Trump said.
He said,
he said a month ago when this first broke,
he said,
I see the left.
So compartmentalize,
I'm saying,
are the less mainstream media,
whatever.
We're so censored now.
They're making their move right now.
Who's they?
The globalist technocracy the mad scientist.
The guys that are one to learn the secrets of the universe,
probably only handling.
So what you're saying is a lot of this censorship allow us is about one mil.
I don't have 10 million.
I will give before God and country to Jamie's.
Uh,
I'm not kidding.
I will give $1 million to your charity of choice.
All right.
Now listen to me.
This is serious change.
Come out eight children.
I'll give you $1 million if you can prove that I'm making up that the governor
said we keep babies alive after they're born.
We keep them comfortable and then it turns out he's an organ harvesting thing
and that's what they're doing.
So they keep babies alive.
Don't go to Snopes.
Go to the governor,
go to the governor of Virginia and that's why they want to head and burning for
the black face.
But they were using the blackmailing.
They already had that on him as soon.
Same Guy,
same guy.
As soon as he sailing as soon as Trump and we all cover it.
As soon as he tweeted,
he said,
yes,
we're getting rid of babies after they're already born.
You don't want none of that.
No.
Already have figured out with George Soros was putting in it right
now.
I mean,
I over simplify that in the media took that.
I know I said they've weaponized marijuana into an hallucinogen category,
so it causes more schizophrenia.
I think he does.
I said that two years is going to court angry.
Yeah,
I think it does.
I think it does for certain people.
I a lot of friends who were already susceptible and the weeds so strong that
that,
that they start thinking that I'm wearing swastika shoes.
No,
listen,
I agree with you on that.
I mean I think I have a strong alpha types needed to not have a heart attack.
Well,
I don't know if I needed to not have a,
when you wanted me to smoke pot with you in that,
in that bathroom,
shooting a video like as a joke like 20 years ago.
Yeah.
Then I said,
it makes me paranoid.
Yeah,
that was funny,
Joe.
The only time I feel fell we were weird.
Fucking George Bush and George Bush senior master dancing around the capitol.
I was fun time.
You value the paste and leave the song that you wrote.
You have to a fucking song about it,
Jamie.
Jamie,
this is a joke.
I will give $1 million.
You don't have to give any money,
but I believe you.
I just want a little bit.
I have skin in the game.
I didn't pull it up on my phone.
I believe you.
I mean,
he's going to find it.
We'll listen to it.
You don't have to when we're listening to you and then he uses these arguments.
He uses these arguments.
He goes,
well,
sometimes it was a baby.
Sometimes the baby is is just the phone.
No,
they want the organs and so who sold the planned parenthood videos out a Texas
to California two years ago,
the project Veritas,
others,
God who are there saying,
I'm getting a yellow Ferrari,
man.
I'm making hundreds of thousands off each baby.
We partial birth.
They keep the baby alive,
they take it in the back and then they have a van pull up that takes it to a
Chinese government run facility in the u s and they got the soccer.
Let's listen to this division after birth.
The boards.
This is a gym.
Okay.
Oh,
is this it?
Alex?
Yeah.
Okay.
Hearing yesterday when Fairfax County delegate,
Kathy Tran made her case for lifting restrictions on third trimester abortions
as well as other restrictions now in place.
And she was pressed by Republican delegate about whether her bill would permit
an abortion even as a woman is essentially dilating ready to give birth.
And she answered that it would permit an abortion at that stage of labor.
Do you support her measure and an explain her answer.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
I wasn't there.
Uh,
Julie and I certainly can't speak for,
uh,
delegate Tran.
But,
um,
I will tell you one first thing I would say.
This is why decisions such as this should be made by providers,
physicians,
uh,
and,
the,
uh,
mothers and fathers that are involved.
Jan had been interrupted her arm back up two seconds.
Notice he's usurping law,
but their whole plan is bioethics and explain in a minute,
but let's let him let him
two minutes.
Ah,
mothers and fathers that are involved.
Um,
there are,
you know,
when we talk about third trimester abortions,
these are done with the consent of obviously the mother with the consent of the
physicians more than one physician by the way.
Um,
and it's done in cases where there may be severe deformities,
there may be a,
a fetus that's non Bible.
So in this particular example,
if a mother is in labor,
I can tell you exactly what would happen.
The infant would be delivered,
uh,
the infant would be kept comfortable.
Uh,
infant would be resuscitated if,
if that's what the mother and the family desired.
And then a discussion would ensue between the physicians and the mother.
So,
so I think this was really blown out of proportion.
But again,
we want the government not to be involved in these types of decisions.
We want the decision to be made by,
uh,
the mothers and their providers.
And,
and this is why Julie,
that legislators,
most of whom are men by the way,
shouldn't be telling a woman what she should and shouldn't be doing with our
body.
And do you think multiple physicians should have to weigh in as is currently
required?
She's trying to lift that requirement.
Well,
I think it's always good to get a second opinion and for,
for at least two providers to be involved in that decision because these
decisions shouldn't be taken lightly and I would certainly support more than one
provider
go back to the front.
Wow.
That's a weird thing that she just kind of let him say [inaudible] story,
but hold on a second.
It's,
what's weird is that she was talking,
they were talking about resuscitating the baby,
that they would keep the baby alive.
Then a decision would be made.
Isn't that,
that's like euthanasia.
Like you can't even do that while you're so smart gentleman cause your ass,
but you can't do that to your grammy.
Right.
Your grandma,
he's like 80 years old.
You can't,
you can't just kill her.
The Newsweek cover it.
The case for killing her auntie.
They say that.
So let me explain.
Now you've got it.
Did you hear that?
Legal ease turns out when I saw that clip a month ago,
cause they had them do a debate about the bill,
right?
And they said,
yeah,
we'll kill babies after they're born.
And they're debating,
well how,
how far along what?
Whatever the doctor say.
But its jurisprudence,
there's law,
you can't do that.
So this is saying,
oh the government not involved.
This is the medical system you surfing.
If they can kill a baby after it's born.
Cause sometimes they deformed,
he knows he has,
sometimes they the phone.
Here's the key.
Notice he shed.
We resuscitate.
They don't consider you alive till the bio ethics board shares that you're a
viable human.
And under the bioethics in Europe and under the UN now,
which is all Nazi by the EU,
was set up by the Nazis.
Volkswagen,
I'm not against Volkswagen itself,
but that,
that was literally drawn the first of all Texas by Hitler,
Audi,
the Olympic symbol.
I mean,
Hitler was a really bad dude,
but he literally,
so much of our world's government,
NASA,
everything,
they had a system where they first killed babies,
they thought were deformed.
That was 1934 the final solution happened like six,
seven years later.
And so he's saying because they've got a big problem,
they've got an undercover videos are keeping babies alive.
You want to pull those up.
I'm up BSA,
there's hot,
there's dozens.
So they've got to start getting it going now with governor physicians in people
to go,
because the nurses are freaking out and they're saying we're keeping babies
alive,
and they get put in a van and drive away what's going on.
They're like,
oh,
well what do we keep them comfortable?
Show the baby's worth $500,000 who's paying the in the chain of delivery just on
time delivery?
I mean,
each organ is worth a lot of money and so,
but,
but if you kill them,
run on the spot.
They were like,
wow,
we wasted in this seven pounds of meat.
So see if they can keep them alive.
And now they've built these new wings.
They've built new ag so I can shut,
pull up a book.
They have wings where they go,
oh,
we consider the baby dead.
The mother decided it did live.
If she decides we resuscitate and it lives,
but it didn't resuscitate,
it's flesh.
It's illegal ease.
It's passed into a special ward with doctors and make a few million a year and a
little foolish.
Bolo is kept alive and comfortable until all the oldest come in the planes land
and they take the logins.
Then they take this blood and they take the skin Joe,
and you see how it works.
Now you know with his voice?
No,
no,
but see as the southern Leb and bullets,
you see,
my dad knew Oregon Harvesters in Dallas and he shed,
don't sign your organ donor card.
They've got corrupt hospitals where if you are totally viable,
they take your organs.
Oh Jeez.
And then I said,
dad,
you're crazy.
But I didn't send the donor card.
And then my dad owned a hospital,
two in Dallas.
Then when I was deck,
a decade later at my grandparents house before my grandpa died watching 60
minutes and it was Dallas,
Texas and Chicago caught killing people that were viable to take their organs
tonight they 60 minutes expos a and it was a freaking hospital.
My Dad told me about Jesus Christ.
So Joe,
that's what I'm telling you is,
were you at the kitchen table when you were eight hearing about cyborgs t that's
why I know about this.
My Dad never got fully into it.
He decided to get out of it
and he decided to get out of it.
He decided that you're legitimately freaking me the fuck out Joe.
I will.
I will let you know.
The problem is some of it makes sense because people figure out a way to
rationalize a lot of things and if you see a guy's mangled in a car accidents,
but he's still alive and you know you could sell the broken,
he can save five loaves.
Yeah.
Kim,
comfortable.
Yeah.
I mean Joe,
but the thing is how many people would have to be involved for that to be real
show.
I can show you.
Let's not exaggerate.
15 videos of planned parenthood workers laughing,
saying,
I made 1 million bucks yesterday,
last year.
It's incredible.
If we could just keep them alive longer,
we'll get 10 times the money.
We're only getting 50 grand per baby cause we got to kill them before they leave
the building.
The mother doesn't know their,
they talk her into it.
Oh ma'am,
you're three months pregnant.
All the baby might have a problem.
Might have a heart murmur.
Oh,
the ultrasound.
Oh yeah.
And then they get the uterus.
You're going to get to,
this is the truth.
Yeah.
They then keep it alive,
but only a few hours and they got to get planes coming in and vans and they
don't get the full price because they can't put it on the auctions.
They've got digital corporate auctions.
Look this up for organs.